si dans les 10 ans on renverse pas la
vapeur et bien on va la catastrophe
écologique qui nous coûtera beaucoup
plus que la crise d'aujourd'hui qui est
déjà quelque chose de dramatique
Daniel condamné très heureux de vous
avoir ce soir rassurez-vous Daniel on va
pas faire l'émission sur mai 68 mais je
voulais vous dire que vous avez changé
ma vie voilà c'est pas rien
et je voulais vous dire aussi que la
fameuse photo avec le CRS elle est
accrochée chez moi depuis l'époque c'est
une des seules photos accrochées chez
moi où je suis pas dessus
voilà alors à l'époque on vous appelez
Dani le rouge maintenant c'est Borlo en
dit Jean-Louis le rouge mais c'est pas
pour les pour les mêmes raisons
alors vous êtes Dany le vert aujourd'hui
vous êtes écologiste est-ce que vous
êtes disponible en d'autres couleurs
le 4 avril prochain vous allez avoir 64
ans vous êtes très en forme le oui enfin
j'ai un peu mal au dos un peu mal à la
hanche mais ça va aujourd'hui jeter un
pavé vous croyez que je vais vous péter
le dos si vous faites ça
c'est pas d'actualité mais pas encore
votre père avocat berlinois déjà proche
des gauchistes de l'époque qu'on
appelait les spartakis avocat du Secours
Rouge ami danarante vous avez une lourde
hérédité politique quand même au départ
pas lourde agréable
non j'ai oui c'est vrai que je suis venu
à la politique par le hasard de ma
famille alors votre père s'appelait Eric
il a quitté l'Allemagne nazie en 1933 il
a rencontré votre mère à Berlin ils sont
venus tous les deux à Paris
et votre frère aîné
Gabriel est né en 1936 ensuite la guerre
et le nazisme ont poussé votre famille à
quitter Paris pour Montauban alors vous
êtes né vous en 45 vous dites un enfant
de la Libération conçu lors du
débarquement c'est beau ça vous faites
40 4 juin 44 un peu de biologie 9 mois
et ça fait avril 45 voilà
l'enfant de la liberté
exact alors en 1949 votre père rentre en
Allemagne où il mourra en 1959 quatre
ans plus tard c'est votre mère airtaki
décède il vous reste votre frère Gabriel
qui a une grosse influence sur vous ça a
été un peu votre maître non j'ai eu un
parcours politique un peu derrière lui
ce qui m'a ce qui m'a formé quoi alors
justement vous le retrouvez en France
après le bac que vous avez passé en
Allemagne vous venez faire des études de
sociologie à Nanterre en 1967 et là en
février 68 l'état offre une piscine aux
étudi Nanterre et lors de l'inauguration
du bassin du campus vous étudiant
apostropher le ministre de la Jeunesse
et des Sports pour lui parler des
problèmes sexuels des étudiants sur la
genèse
et sur les problèmes de la jeunesse et
là je lui ai dit il manque quand même un
truc c'est l'émancipation sexuelle des
jeunes c'est quand même un problème dans
nos sociétés la pilule venant et c'est
là qu'il a dit mais monsieur si vous
avez des problèmes à les plonger dans la
piscine
j'ai pas apprécié bon vous auriez fait
quoi dans la vie s'il y avait pas eu mes
68 je voulais en ayant passé mon bac je
voulais faire des études de maths et de
sociologie pour être planificateur de
l'éducation
[Rires]
aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est plus possible les
étudiants c'est plus du tout la même
chose aujourd'hui ça serait SMS
nécessaire pour protester contre contre
le prix des textos quoi pas mal ça c'est
pas mal et pas mal j'en ai une autre
alors aujourd'hui les gens en mais ils
ont plutôt envie de faire le pont que la
révolution quoi
c'est vrai c'est vrai aussi
malheureusement non moi je crois que
sérieusement le problème c'est que c'est
beaucoup plus dur d'être jeune
aujourd'hui qu'il y a 50 ans nous on
était Prométhée on n'avait pas on avait
peur de rien l'avenir nous appartient on
disait c'est à nous de faire de gérer
notre avenir aujourd'hui les jeunes
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent on veut un
avenir
et c'est pas la même chose
le SIDA on connaissait pas
le chômage on connaissait pas la
dégradation climatique on connaissait
pas donc je dis on est dans une dans un
monde où j'ai beaucoup plus angoissant
que n'était le monde le monde à la fin
des années 60 alors aujourd'hui vous
êtes passé de l'anarchie à l'écologie
vous êtes le seul écolo à préférer la
ville à la campagne bon pas être seul
parce que les grands les résultats les
écolos les meilleurs sont toujours dans
les villes oui donc je suis pas le seul
alors vous êtes député Vert européen et
vous conduisez la liste Europe
écologique je rassemblement Europe
Écologie d'ailleurs si on veut savoir ce
que c'est c'est WW Europe écologie.fr
ben voilà et ça vous dérange pas que
José Bové qu'a voté non au référendum
sur la Constitution européenne soit sur
votre liste non parce que justement José
et moi et Eva Joly on est d'accord quand
on dit ou voilà face à la crise il faut
passer par l'Europe l'Europe doit donner
des réponses il faut une politique
conséquente écologique de transformation
de nos modes de production et là on est
d'accord donc ça va très bien
mais je vous assure que c'est
intéressant et c'est même touchant les
mythiques qu'on fait ensemble on voit
des tas de gens qui sont contents
qui sont revenus et qui étaient
désespérés avant vous êtes incroyable
quand même c'est à dire que vous avez
toujours LA
alors vous avez une formule qui est
vachement bien c'est l'ambition de la
liste Europe écologique c'est de
rassembler ceux qui ont peur de la fin
du mois et ceux qui ont peur de la fin
du monde
ça c'est c'est ça le le problème de de
aujourd'hui qu'on a crise économique
c'est un peu comme si vous avez un
chômeur
et sa maison brûle alors vous pouvez pas
dire au chômeur occupe-toi d'abord de
ton chômage tu verras pour ta maison il
est obligé de régler les deux problèmes
en même temps la planète brûle regardez
l'Australie la dégradation climatique
est catastrophique 5 degrés de
réchauffement ferait que Saint-Brieuc
serait sur une île ah ouais ah oui non
mais attention là c'est pas on joue pas
et que tout le monde dit si dans les 10
ans on renverse pas la vapeur et bien on
va la catastrophe écologique qui nous
coûtera beaucoup plus que la crise
d'aujourd'hui qui est déjà quelque chose
de dramatique justement est-ce qu'il
faut être pour la croissance verte ou
pour moins consommer parce que c'est pas
du tout la même chose qu'est-ce qui nous
a mis dans le mur c'est le toujours plus
toujours plus vite par exemple il y a
quelqu'un d'assez connu en France qui a
dit travailler plus pour gagner plus bah
les gens travaillent moins ils gagnent
moins c'est ça le résultat aujourd'hui
non il y a une erreur dans le casting il
y a un problème là et pourquoi parce que
le système est devenu complètement fou
et le problème c'est pas de relancer le
même système qui va redevenir fou c'est
changer la dynamique la structure de ce
système je vous donne un exemple très
simple il y a 12 ans les verres
européens avaient proposé une loi
européenne qui dit aucune voiture dans
les 10 ans ne doit consommer plus de 6
litres au sang si ça avait été le cas
tout le monde payerait moins les sens
vous auriez d'autres voitures et donc
tout le monde aurait plus d'argent dans
son porte-monnaie donc le problème c'est
de réguler notre système pour que les
gens peuvent travailler autrement pour
vivre mieux c'est ça notre mot d'ordre
et vivre mieux ce n'est pas simplement
consommer mais ça Daniel nous c'est
possible encore de consommer moins mais
comment expliquer ça des pays comme la
Chine comme l'Inde ils vont nous dire
vous vous avez le tout le confort et
maintenant vous vous calmez un peu mais
nous on a rien non mais écoutez regardez
les Chinois les Chinois aujourd'hui qui
ont une croissance de
10-12%. ils ont une dégra écologique une
impossibilité de vivre aujourd'hui vous
avez 32 millions de personnes qui n'ont
plus de travail qui sont en vadrouille
des nomades en Chine la manière dont la
Chine se construit se fait aujourd'hui
détruit la Chine c'est ça le problème il
y a des écolos en Chine oui il y en a on
les met en prison ah oui d'accord
quand le gouvernement pour lutter contre
le chômage donne des milliards d'euros à
des fabricants automobiles qui font des
voitures qui sont équipées de moteur à
explosion donc de moteur salle c'est
complètement con si c'est investir dans
l'automobile pour construire les mêmes
voitures ça ne marchera pas ce qu'il
faut par contre c'est par exemple ce
qu'on propose nous un salaire de
transformation c'est à dire que 10% de
ces sommes vont à l'aide à la
transformation sociale à ceux qui sont
victimes de la crise aujourd'hui pour
que ils ne perdent pas leur travail ou
s'il le ils aient une chance parce
qu'ils sont payés de se former pour
faire autre chose je croyez que ça peut
arriver ça ben vous savez c'est dans les
crises que tout d'un coup les sociétés
s'aperçoivent qu'il faut changer en 1929
par exemple
les Américains ont créé la Réserve
fédérale avant il y avait pas assez dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'une réserve
européenne un trésor européen qui émet
des bons européens pour financer la
reconversion nécessaire est-ce que vous
croyez pas que ce qui manque finalement
c'est une gouvernance mondiale
c'est-à-dire que si l'ONU avait plus de
pouvoir et pouvait imposer des choses ça
marcherait mieux aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que tout le monde tire dans son
coin pour qu'il y ait une gouvernance
mondiale il faut d'abord que par exemple
la gouvernance européenne intégrée
permettrait de faire ses propositions
donc proposer que l'Europe soit
représentée en tant qu'Europe au Conseil
de sécurité je voudrais dire que la
France abandonnerait sa place pour la
donner à l'Europe oui mais c'est comme
ce débat sur le temps
gérant le temps aujourd'hui ce dont on a
besoin c'est une force d'intervention
civile et militaire liés au Conseil de
sécurité lié à l'ONU une défense
européenne mais l'OTAN même si on y est
intégré les Russes c'est les blancs
contre les autres c'est les riches
contre les autres et ça peut pas
fonctionner dans le monde actuel
cette liste aux Européennes pensées
faire combien
Europe Écologie
je sais pas moi j'ai dit 10 + x on a
reçu un mail de Julien Courbet qu'il y a
attention 10% c'est très difficile
Daniel
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu